welcome to another episode of get close
i am your host
that's cohen
with bart and my name is geo and i'm
bart
the other coast
coast yeah co-host oh
that only applies in california you know
that i don't even know if that's around
anymore
what do you mean coast 103.5 it might
have been bought out by another radio
station
3.5 that's like what did they use
like all the slow jams of the 80s and
90s uh what kind of slow jams because
there's like r b but there's pop
[Music]
just
oh like brian mcknight yeah stuff like
that oh like [ __ ] you can listen to you
can play
uh if you work at a dentist
[Music]
so i was watching tick tock and they
were saying i don't know how accurate
this is i didn't look it up so i
shouldn't
spread this information but who am i
um
they're talking about that there's two
types of people right people yeah okay
two types of people okay it's dry out
here okay sometimes my lips get stuck to
my [ __ ] pearly whites
um there's two types of people
my self-conscious yeah you told me
something i'm sticking i'm looking i'm
like are they are gonna stick now yeah
or now uh so
when listening to music
one person or one type will listen to
the words
and they just hear words and it's hard
for them like they have to like for not
force themselves but they have to like
really pay attention and then like to to
have to listen to the music right that's
not me and then there's people that
listen to the music first and then they
don't even hear the words really i don't
hear words ever so you only hear music
that's why it's so hard for me to
memorize music like lyrics
even the lyrics that i write
it's hard for me to memorize really yeah
what do you hear i hear
sounds
and even and feel emotions
how do you feel the emotion if you're
not even hearing oh like just the way
they're singing it so like yeah you can
feel it
they're saying but i'm so happy yeah
like you know what they go like you're
going
that's literally how you sing
oh i just feel it that's so interesting
because they say the person that listens
to the words operates on more logic
i'm definitely not logical
what the [ __ ]
are we in [ __ ] upside down world
maybe i'm so emotional that i'm logical
how does that make sense i don't know
yeah and what's interesting is that i
listen to words for me i'm always like
i don't know i feel like i'm right in
the middle too honestly i feel like i
can hear a lot you know all the lyrics
to all the songs you for sure listen to
the words ah yeah but then there's
certain parts of a solo that i [ __ ]
love or maybe because there is no words
and finally i can listen to the music
yeah but i don't hear that interesting
no words even songs i just memorized i'm
like i still don't even know i wonder
why i want to hear the words so much
well they say that obviously you operate
on more logic which i think is all total
bs i think everything is all bs because
there's obviously like a spectrum to
[ __ ] everything yeah and it's on tick
tock which means it's bs
it's the truth dude that's true
everything on tick tock is real
especially when they're 15 and they're
well yeah he looks he looks old but he's
probably young you know those type of
people yeah he's like that
um and i thought that was so interesting
and it and then i was like i wonder if
bart is a words person because he's so
logical or if he's like a music person
and i'm like but he's definitely a music
person because he doesn't know any
goddamn lyrics to any song you know if
we were to get selected on that game or
like finish the rest of the song oh i
lose every time
okay go close your eyes
make a wish
[Music]
is just
your night
we're gonna celebrate
all through the night
oh [ __ ] you actually know that one and
it's because i know this song for like
over 20 years oh what's one that you uh
uh uh what about uh
na na na na na na
na na na
oh chris brown
[ __ ] life
no he doesn't say that at all what did
you say oh god damn it well you know
what he does say what he says
but also fun what's his name oh chris
brown what's the name of his that
live your life live your life
live your [ __ ] lives let the love
inside oh okay it's your life it's your
life
your beauty's deep inside
don't let them bring you down no
your beauty is inside
you
don't let them bring you down no
yeah
what
interesting i don't know now lyrics
player yeah the one that [ __ ] threw
me for a loop dude yeah the one that
threw me for a loop is when i found out
that people
don't hear a voice in their goddamn head
that is pretty crazy
i was like what i don't know if i've met
anyone like that oh we knew someone like
that but i didn't get to pick their
brain it's crazy though cause like why
is it crazy why are we calling them out
they're weird crazy to me because i
obviously have voices in my head that i
talk to back and forth same right and i
feel like like you know when you when
you when the guy at the car dealership
is like hey you want to buy it or what
and you're thinking i should do it
maybe i shouldn't like what do they do
they just go yes
no they're still thinking about it but
there's just no voice now i think it's
just how do they think about it the
visual so now they're like visualizing
everything there is no voice but it's
just all pictures okay well that that
makes sense then yeah of course it makes
sense because for us they wouldn't be
functioning people well i just thought
it was just all impulse you know
so i'm like okay least at least they're
thinking at least they're thinking
now i gotta read it again but yeah i
remember going like
oh [ __ ]
we are all so similar but so [ __ ]
different
okay now with the voices in your head
right because we can only talk about
uh head voice people
when
you're deciding something is it your own
voice going back and forth yup
is there ever any other voices in there
um it's
it could be other people's content but
it's my voice insane so it could be like
a lesson my mom told me i don't forget
to do this one you might hear that but i
don't i just oh don't forget to do that
one you know
yeah yeah no i'll be like
i'll hear myself mimicking my mom's
voice for example going uh i already
told you geo like me you know what i
mean like literally how you made your
mom's voice right now is that voice
myself in yeah
so interesting what about when you read
i want to read yeah it's my voice
some people say oh sometimes it's other
people's voices too
true okay i can see that depending if
you know what they sound like time out
why do i not hear myself on the
headphones did it just cut out or was it
always just right now hold on a second
technical difficulties
okay okay there's just the headphones
keep going
i want to read this inside head voice
versus
oh internal monologue that's what it's
called internal monologue yeah
or what does i say oh about reading
um so oh sometimes i read it in the
other person's voice too if i know them
enough right that makes sense so i've
been reading uh like when i was reading
um this was not a t-shirt by bobby
hundreds
i was reading it in his voice and then
when i was reading extreme ownership it
was in joko's voice yeah that guy
both have very different voices
but usually it's in my voice
same
do you think you're schizophrenic then
if you start hearing other people's
voices no
okay all those like terms
for like the um
psychological like disorders there's a
specific chart side dm whatever dfvm or
whatever
i i think we all are it
it's just some people have the volume
cranked up i see
like i think everyone has a little bit
of hd adhd i agree um
it's just the people that have it
have it all some form you know everyone
probably has a little bit of
schizophrenia maybe even one percent
yeah and then we're just all
spectrums of it that's how i feel yeah i
agree um but yeah that internal
monologue was so interesting to me
because i was just like
dang how did they do it and then i
started reading into it and then um
um
there were just people that had it that
were so so people that don't have the
internal monologue are tripping over
people that do they're like wait
so like there's just always noise in
your head and i'm like
oh
they didn't ask me personally but like
in the beginning
yeah
and then they were just so blown away
they're like that is [ __ ] weird
and we're going no you're [ __ ] weird
and they're going oh you're [ __ ]
weird i would like to see
like uh all the successful people
um how many of them
have voices and then i would also like
to see all the happy people
people who rate who like rate very high
in their happiness meter
what they hear or see why that'd be
interesting why just to see like if if a
certain
character trait um tends to succeed
versus others yeah like you know like
they they tested a lot of extreme sports
guys
and a lot of them have adhd
and it's because uh people with adhd
they're so
focusing on everything
the only time they're really stimulated
where they can hone in is when their
life is on the line yeah when it's
extremely extremely stimulating and so
because of that that's when they're like
endorphins is really firing and that's
when they wow i like how it feels to be
this focused for once in my life
have you ever felt that as someone that
lives with adhd yeah like when you do
jiu-jitsu
uh you know for that round i don't know
i don't know i don't remember much else
besides that round sometimes my adhd
will still sneak in you know but that's
what allows it to be creative because
the misnomer is they think adhd you
can't focus it's actually you focus on
too many things right and that's why a
lot of adhd people tend to be creative
because like let's say i'm in a jiu
jitsu move yeah i'm still able to think
multi-layer like i can beat in this
grappling match think about other things
i want to try yes or no have
conversations in my head
while looking at the time well what
should i eat later all at the same
intensity and so that allows you to like
you know be creative like whether
they're doing stand-up like okay my joke
okay scrolls like this but it feels like
i need to go this way and you say
another joke that really kills or when
you're singing goes
and you're like usually i'm supposed to
hit this note but instead of oh i'm
gonna go
like whoa that's a crazy feeling you
know
what do you think the difference then is
so like um you know how guy and girl
conversations are very different like
guy conversation is pretty linear yeah
what's up bros up
and then girl conversation is like oh my
god
that's it that's the difference it can
go into like so we can be having a
conversation about five different things
at the exact same time yeah okay not at
the exact same time but we can bounce
back and forth yeah yeah what's the
difference then i think that's
multitasking
what's the difference
um the difference is
that's a good question it's a really
good question thank you i don't i don't
have them a lot yeah
but when i do
it shuts bart the [ __ ] up
i think
adhd
makes you good at multitasking
but i don't think it's the other way
around and when you guys are having
conversations all over the place
um
none of that is extremely stimulating
it's not life or death
you know nothing is on the line like if
i don't nail this joke
5 000 people are going to boo me
right none of it is very stimulating so
i think it's very like
it's like multitasking i think the
difference is
adhd
it um
you're focused on something that's
extremely stimulating
but that doesn't mean
you can um i think they're two different
skills i don't think just because you
have adhd can make you multitask either
because i think for in in order for the
power of adhd to work
because sometimes it can be a detriment
right i think for in order for the power
for it to work
it needs to be able to focus first
then it comes into play so for example
when you're grappling or when you're
pushed
then you're like oh [ __ ] i got this
extra like
extra wavelength that i can think about
but if you're just unstimulated then the
adhd it's a useless power
so i think when it comes to like oh my
god i just see what kind of shoes she
has oh i had omelettes for breakfast
like none of that is very like
stimulating so nothing is to focus on so
i think adhd someone could probably have
adhd and multitask but they're not using
the adhd for multitasking i see yeah
because i notice my adhd comes out when
i'm like in the zone
when i'm in the zone and then i can feel
almost like two three four other heads
popped up and i'm able to harness that
power
you know no i don't know
what the [ __ ] yeah like i'll be like
let's say i'm in the zone on something
or i procrastinate i don't have an hour
then all of a sudden is like
and it's almost like four heads thinking
at the same time and i'm like oh [ __ ]
going crazy
if not then i'm [ __ ] getting in
trouble because i'm i'm constantly
trying to focus on other stuff and i
think that's what tiger gets in trouble
damn
i wish i knew what that felt like almost
like uh
or maybe i do know but i don't know that
i know what that feels like
like it's like uh
like you know when you play basketball
or maybe volleyball right like you're in
the zone and then you know what you're
supposed to do but then you also see
there's like three other lines on the
court
that can go a different way
and then you're like but what if the
ball comes
and then i [ __ ] chew on it then the
crowd are gonna think i'm crazy
and you're thinking about the same all
those thoughts at the same time that is
crazy bones
yes you're like maybe i shouldn't chew
on the ball or maybe i should because
it'd be crazy
and you're having that conversation
in the flow oh my god i can't have that
yeah it's like that no mine is way more
i guess and i think i'm
i don't know if i'm one of the probably
not definitely one of the few but i
definitely feel like in my age now and
my age and over the decade or two of
entrepreneurship and like just like
creative expression i think i've been
able to harness my adhd power so i love
it it's not something that it was like
in school that distracted me i couldn't
focus and got me into a lot of trouble
now all of my output i bank on it you
know
so like i actually love having adhd
and i think that's where all my craziest
jokes come from on jk news
because we're in the moment in the zone
and then i'm like this makes me think of
that makes me think of that and then
there's almost like i have a writer's
room in my brain and i can almost sort
in milliseconds this one's the funniest
go damn that's nuts and you were also
forced to [ __ ] think hella fast as a
kid yeah what's 6464 boom yeah
dang
no for me if i get caught trying to
think of
different
layers of it
i then i've missed everything else
because i'm just so in the zone that i'm
gone
i'm not present anymore
i'm just in my own head off i'm
extremely present when the adhd no i'm
out of here i see i could be staring at
it but it's productive adhd i'm present
because i'm focused that's what i'm
saying that's right that's the that's
the key thing the the teeth have to sink
in
and once it's grabbing on then the
forehead's popped out or else it'll be
like that where it's just a bunch of
brainstorms all over the place you're
not even here someone talks to you like
huh
because you weren't even here you're
just thinking about some other [ __ ]
it's unproductive that's crazy now my
extreme focus comes from
extreme focus literally that like i have
to be focused i'm like locked into your
eyes i'm not feeling anything thinking
anything i'm just grabbing on to every
single word i don't know what that feels
like
i've never been zoned into one thing in
my life
damn yeah it's always at least
three things
no i for me it like i can even for like
i just realized there's like someone's
mowing a lawn or some [ __ ] right now but
like when i'm present
it's just you and i and it's literally
blinders
and like this but like just i just hear
you mine's like you and i and then i'm
like you use great laundry detergent it
smells very good it's like all of that
at the same time
[ __ ]
that's crazy all right do any of your
parents have it did they have it i don't
know my dad probably has it i don't know
i have no idea you say he does when you
guys are talking you're like this guy
has [ __ ] adhd he also just has asian
dad syndrome he doesn't give a [ __ ]
about what you're saying it's all about
him oh so that's an asian dad thing i
think so you could tell them something
like hey dad what do you think about the
car is it do you think you're gonna be
okay with the car battery he goes
uh so what are you gonna take me to
whatever oh my god do you think he's
just deaf nah he's been like that a lot
of asian dads are like that oh he just
doesn't give up they just run you over
like in the conversation they just
[ __ ]
[Music]
that's it
always
damn yeah i don't know what that feels
like really yeah no i don't know what
that feels parents never talk to you
like that no
oh yeah you're just always gonna run
over no matter what
ah they'll let you say whatever
and they might like no my daughter just
straight cut me off everything's
[ __ ] you just say what do you need
to say yeah
that's gnarly
speaking of your dad um
you've always talked about how turbulent
your relationship has been with him yeah
yeah um
and you're talking about right now the
[ __ ]
[ __ ] runs your ass over all the time
yeah and you've had a long stint
of your life where you haven't
cohabitated with him yeah i want to say
what [ __ ] maybe 20 plus years
yeah yeah yeah um
we live in vegas now yeah he's like
you're my life bart you and tyka are my
life
um
what what why would i need to stay in
california if my life is in nevada so
now he's bought property out here
currently in the middle of getting built
um and it didn't make sense for him to
stay in california as that gets built
and then [ __ ]
uh prices skyrocket so we were like yo
just live with us until your property is
done get it buy low
um
and and just hang out here yeah he's
been living with us for maybe a month
now yeah how has that
been uh
bittersweet
okay
i think you know like before you jump
into anything it's always very like
romantic romantic right oh cuny
tiger gets to be with his grandpa
grandpa gets to be with taika it's going
to be so cute here we have more family
out here and i get to like uh help my
dad out because he is older and i do
recognize that
and then so that's all the sweet stuff
the bitter stuff is um
i forgot how annoying he is
and so i'm like what makes him annoying
because i don't know anything about him
because uh he only speaks
chinese
and he's deaf
i think those are the two things that
make him annoying oh that sucks yeah
it's like oh wait that he only speaks
chinese
that he's chinese so he has chinese
thought process
which is what you're saying so many
things they do not understand bro and
then i'm waiting for you to ask
questions i can answer them god what is
that what does that all mean chinese so
uh chinese thought process yeah you dumb
i'm smart
that's a chinese that's chinese thought
process yeah
and
what makes them so smart and you so dumb
they're chinese that they're not
oh so if you're not chinese you're dumb
if you're not if you're not the chinese
dad you're dumb
okay like yesterday i was trying to help
my dad change his car battery right
they're so funny because i saw that ex
exchange yeah and i knew exactly what
happened it was pissing me the [ __ ] off
can i can i tell you what happened yeah
this is from my perspective okay so your
dad's car battery has died
and um
he's been
on it for like two days you were in
california still i was out here and he
couldn't wait so much again def doesn't
speak english but he just was so
impatient that he was like hey can you
go take me to get a battery cool we go
get it the following day all day
literally all day he's trying to swap
out this battery he doesn't know how i
think at some point he was trying to ask
me how to open the car the car hood yeah
but i was on my way out because i need
to pick up taika and that has to be
on the money or else they're going to
send them to this other classroom and
he's going to get scared anyway um
so that's how impatient and honest he's
been you finally get in
he
grabs a hold of you
and you're like no i can't because i'm
working so i'll i i have my commitments
i'll do it for you at four o'clock it
was 402 he's going to go get you yeah he
finally gets you you guys are out front
um
he opens the
oh he's trying to open it
but like he doesn't know how
and he's hovering over you as you're
trying to like unhook it or whatever but
he's so on you that you're just like and
he's telling you what to do
so as he's telling you what to do you're
going wait a minute you asked me for
help can you please give me space so
that i can do what i need to do because
you already don't know what you're doing
yeah he doesn't know how to do it is
that what happened yeah he doesn't know
how to do it right which is why he the
car hood is open for the whole day
and then he asked me for help
while i'm helping him he's trying to
help me with his don't know how to do it
brains like what was he saying
like he'll be like oh you got to open
the hood i'm like i know you don't know
how to open i'm like you go open it then
and it goes no no i don't know how to do
it i'm okay cool so as soon as i stick
my finger there he starts
i'm like there's no space it's like so
small right so i'm like stop sticking
your fingers in because i need to feel
it because as soon as i stick mine he
goes like this then i can't wiggle it
around so i'm like that i'm like
can you stand over there please and then
he's just like
he goes and he walks away i'm like
stay right there okay
and then as soon as i go he comes back
again and i'm like dad do you need me to
help you or not i'm gonna do you are you
gonna do it or you want me to do it
so finally i open it and then i find out
he bought the wrong battery and then i
was like hey dad you bought the wrong
battery that's why it doesn't fit i even
had asked him you know that i was like
do you know what battery size you need
and then he goes
uh
i don't know and i was like maybe take a
picture he goes i did
and i'm like okay what gear make is your
car and he goes i don't know
yeah i was like you got the wrong
battery i'm like the positive negatives
are on different sides and it's not even
the same size battery and he goes oh
they're not all the same
and i'm like no i'm like are all tires
are the same he goes no he goes why do
they make things so complicated i'm like
i don't know
like i'm supposed to be able to answer
that you know so we go and we go get
another battery
we come back home and this is the more
difficult part because that was just us
going like this so now going like this
yeah trying to figure out what the slide
thing is so now i put the battery in and
then uh he and then as soon as i'm like
getting the pliers he's sticking his
pliers i'm like just there's only space
for one set of pliers i might just move
over there
i'm like dad just go inside please just
go inside and then he's i go back there
and he wants to help me it's like
holding i'm like there's only space
for one person i'm like when people are
working on cars on this item it's one
mechanic at a time i'm like either you
do it which i know you don't know how or
you let me do it are you talking to him
this way yeah and then he's like
and he walks he doesn't say anything he
just laughs no and then so i'm doing it
and i put it together and then uh yeah
and he was telling me like oh should we
cut the handles off you know that the
battery comes with the handle i know i
might look it slides in like this
and he goes what the other one didn't
have it i'm like dad
every single year products
improve on themselves yeah so there's
going to be i was like as you live life
the next 20 years of your life or 10
years
you're going to see a lot of things
going to blow your mind okay
just
just go with the the floor i didn't tell
him that but that's pretty much what i
was letting him know like
obviously because this thing what came
this battery was 10 years old this is
where it's not going to have these cool
new features that this new battery does
yeah so i put it all in and i tightened
it and then i closed it for him
yeah was he always this impatient
oh yeah
and the crazy thing that sucks it's just
to beat the sh beat the [ __ ] out of me
for me being impatient what do you mean
give me an example of a time you were
impatient so like there'll be a time
where like i'm like papa can you know
like taika like can we go to the store
and get a car let's get his little cars
right so my dad will like take me to the
store to go buy some legos or something
for my birthday or i'll beg some i'll
beg him for something for a long long
time he goes fine let's go let's take a
look take a look at it i'm like i want
that lego set and then
oh man it's expensive
legos are expensive and then as we're
walking up the street we can't get that
yet i'm like crying i'm crying you're so
impatient all you want is everything
right now and if something's going away
you get [ __ ] pissed and then you
would just lecture me on that whole
thing right and now when i'm older i'm
like is it a now thing or is it a
[ __ ] always thing no but now that
when i'm older i'm like [ __ ]
what you were yelling me about that's
what you do you're impatient when it
doesn't go your way you get mad you have
anxiety when it doesn't go your way
you're anticipating the whole time and i
think he was just projecting you know
when we're when we're young back in
those days there's nothing like that
we're not self-aware so we don't have
all these words to describe it so he
probably didn't like that about himself
and he saw that in me so he got mad at
me yeah yeah
but yeah he's i think
he has a and i think
in addition to having so much free time
he has extreme anxiety because all he
could think about is that is that yeah
did you do that yet did you do that yet
did you do that yeah and i'm like dad
with my schedule going back and forth in
la whatever i'm like realistic time
frame i'll get to it in two weeks
because you told me it's not urgent if
it's urgent i'll do it right now i'm
like is it urgent or not and he goes no
it's not urgent i'm like okay
in two weeks i'll do it and then every
day did you do it did you do it
like i told you two weeks really yeah so
that's the bitter part that's the better
part but i also just realized you know
what like they're old they're stuck in
their ways so it's just something i just
have to to live with you know i have to
be okay with it and do the positives
outweigh the negatives and that's it and
for me it it does because like seeing
uh
seeing like my dad interacting with
tycoon i was like uh taika is really not
warming up to your dad the other way
the happiness that taika brings my dad
makes me happy
and i think that's super cute yeah
that's the only time i see your dad have
soft eyes
oh yeah yeah like uh
i've only seen you have soft eyes
because you're just you're
it's so ironic that you're not a very
like
expressive person but your eyes are
super expressive your eyes give your
eyes are
the tales of all of your [ __ ] secrets
really yeah like when we played mafia
like any time there's anything going on
your eyes always give me the answers
yeah you always have soft eyes but i've
never seen anyone else have soft eyes
but your dad when he looks at taika
always soft eyes he loves him so much he
does and it's so unfortunate because you
were just talking about how like we
romanticize a lot of things in our brain
so your dad was absolutely romanticizing
what him and taika's relationship was
gonna be like
he was like thinking i'm gonna take him
to the park i'm gonna buy him [ __ ]
happy meals we're going to hang out all
the time we're going to play and like he
gets here and tyka is like ugh get away
dude yeah this morning like tiger looked
all cute so my dad kept trying to like
pet him and he's like my hair my hair
gonna mess with my hair we just gelled
it you know but then my dad can't even
hear
so he doesn't even know that type of
completely cute yeah he just keeps
petting him like hey you're gonna mess
with my hair come on
i know when i feel so bad because your
dad will reach out to like try to like
touch him but i think your dad's way of
affection is like so abrupt for taika
and it's not soft or gentle
um that tyke just goes ah ow
and i'm like hey dude that's so rude you
see how my daddy said pat tyson
yeah he'd be like yeah like and he
[ __ ] pulls his [ __ ] cheeks he's
like his little flaps yeah his mouth
flops and you see tyson go like his eyes
the white of his eyes he's like oh [ __ ]
but he loved
they love each other so much did they
yeah how do you know
my dad like
i think like the amount of what i could
do to tyson
before he gets mad my dad could do like
twice as much oh really yeah i think
tyson just knew how much my dad loved
him and he cooked them food and go
outside and talk to him
bless you kicked out his girlfriend for
him yeah and he would like pet him and
like you know
tyson probably saw that girlfriend when
she [ __ ] beat him and then he was
like and then you came out and you got
mad and he was like yeah thanks dad and
then grandpa came out and tyson was like
oh
you do that for me grandpa and tyson was
like i'm forever loyal yeah
doug sends this [ __ ] yeah no tyson was
such a good dog dogs and kids
sense the genuineness they do in
people's soul man
like if tyson didn't like someone i was
like me neither dude
i know you sent something and i probably
have a hint of it but i'm trusting you
more man excuse me yeah i miss tyson
dude this is a good dog yeah you got him
when he was how old are you were held i
was 15 and he was eight weeks
he was this small big cuny guy yeah
maybe that's what your dad needs he
needs a girlfriend and a dog
i don't know if he could take care of a
dog that's what came in here
what do you need to hear for for him in
case a dog is like caught in the door or
something like a dog could be a whimper
you probably really hear it
that's a good point
all right never mind
yeah okay well i was trying to solve
your dad's loneliness i don't even know
if he's lonely it's my own like
insecurity i guess well he i mean also i
think he just wants to focus his
attention on taika he just loves him so
much
in what way
i think that's the natural evolution you
know i have a kid and now my kid has a
kid so now that's my kid's kid and i
love him okay and that's that's my
attention until i die now yeah that's
cuny
i don't know if my mom is like that
because she has so many grandkids my mom
has
one two three
four five six seven eight eight
grandkids
that's a lot of grandkids i think your
mom
isn't like that
because she has a different perspective
what's her perspective i think her
perspective is uh
i've been the mom and housewife so i've
been in the service industry
for many many many decades and i finally
have time to myself so i just want to
relax and just chill and do my stuff
that's true that's how i feel what's
your mom's perspective
um
i'm an asian mom and i need to [ __ ]
[ __ ] your life up
does she still contact you she contacted
you every day yeah she's [ __ ] texting
me you know that one kid that does like
uh all the bruce lee stuff so a little
kid yeah so old she's texting me things
that are popping off like five years ago
why is she not with the trend so
annoying yeah what does that matter
i i don't know it's just she just annoys
you i think
just i don't know i just still got to
work on it i got to work on my
relationships with both of them dude
mine with my dad i like better right now
because we've been working on it yeah
even though it pisses me off like every
week but it's a good it's better
it's a good test and it helps me
uh
uh battle my own maturity in my own
issues so i like it yeah um
so
i want to say maybe like a few weeks
back you were disciplining taika right
yeah
and i think he wasn't eating or he was
doing something that you ended up having
to put him in timeout your dad didn't
like that
he stepped in you guys kind of had a
minor like fight
split up into he he went into his room
and was like ugh i really don't know
what was happening i could only read
body language um but then you said he
apologized like the next day
is that is that like significant change
for him or has it always been kind of
like that um that's pretty significant
change because he never really
apologized but the story was um taika
kept interrupting adult conversations
when he knows when adults or guests come
over
not to interrupt not that just in
general don't interrupt not that he
can't talk it's just you just have to
wait
right so the patient's coming full
circle yeah so like uh i remember um our
friend christina came over and when you
were talking like he's jumping on the
bed like trying to purposely put on the
show right when we told him don't do
that and then so uh
we talked to him about that and then i
literally just told him hey
and i never tell him i asked him
questions so i know he understands like
hey is it okay to interrupt when mama
and papa are talking to a guest or an
adult no what are you supposed to do i'm
supposed to wait okay cool so next time
when this happens what's gonna happen
i'm gonna go to timeout good so i always
make sure he comes up with the answers
yeah you're so good at that and then um
so that he so it's not a lecture you
know you're never and you're never
emotionally rolled up yeah i want his i
want his brain to work yeah so
i was in the middle of talking with
my dad i believe
and taika comes in and he had like um it
was pretty funny but he wore like his
pants as his hat and he was just going
crazy like this i'm like i literally
talked to you about the 60 seconds i'm
going to go to timeout so he goes to
timeout and uh he's like crying because
he's all sad and my dad just go over and
over there like wiping his tears and on
my dad i mean you don't have to wipe his
tears he's in punishment mode and then
my dad's like kind of like pushes me off
a little bit and then that's when we go
into the bedroom and then i'm like i'm
like dad what is that all about man we
got to be a team yeah you know we're
parenting together
and then he goes he breaks my card i
can't see stuff like that i'm like stuff
like he's so sorry i'm like see stuff
like what he was just just the way
you're just so mean to him and i'm like
you don't even know the whole context
he's like he was trying to make you
laugh and all you do is just set him
straight to timeout i'm like no there's
a lot more context that he goes i don't
want to hear
and then uh he goes you're just so
you're so mean i'm like i have no dumb i
am not i'm smiling yeah and i'm like
i've never
been as mean to him as you've been to me
you said that yeah i said that i've
never i've never been that mean and then
he was just so pissed and he was
he just he he he just waves he just
waves he goes to his bed he just closes
his eyes and just lays there
he's like if i don't see you you don't
see me yeah conversation over
and then i'm like i'm used to that you
know i'm used to me and my dad getting
in the craziest fights and literally the
next day he goes what do you want to
have for lunch like nothing happened so
i'm like all right this is something you
have to swallow put up with it whatever
next day i forgot what we're doing but
it came up
and then um
and then something about parenting
and then i was telling my dad i'm like
yeah you know like the school that we
found for him i i was literally looking
for a school oh i think he was saying
something about i think you told me this
part where you were like yo you know um
i see a lot of similarities in taika
that you had as a baby or as a kid
oh yeah yeah so i think my dad was
saying something like you know like you
know taika is your son right like
meaning like there's a lot of
similarities and whatever he has came
from you
and then i'm like yeah i'm like i know
that i'm like that's why i like
for schools when we're searching i was
looking for a school
not really for taika but mainly for what
i thought i was gonna succeed in because
i didn't succeed in regular academia at
all like it was putting a circle into
like a square peg think you know i'm
like the school that we found small
classrooms uh less than ten two teachers
very hands-on type of curriculum like
you don't just go what's two plus two
it's like okay everyone go in the
kitchen here's two pancakes two slices
of butter how much do we have total in
the kitchen you know it's like very
you're playing with toys and stuff like
that
and uh so i'm like that's why and then
he goes oh man you're you're like a
really good dad uh that you think of
things like that and i'm like i know i'm
like i try really hard to be a good dad
so i'm like when even
when i'm like parenting and stuff i
really think about how i'm saying these
things uh it's not about me getting
things off my chest i want to make sure
things are received on his end
and that he was like you know what maybe
yesterday i misjudged the situation oh
is that him saying sorry yeah he goes i
misjudged the situation and he knows
next time you parent
i'll stay out of it wow
that's pretty crazy what did you
instantly think at that moment i told
you [ __ ]
you're so
[ __ ] in your own [ __ ] why am i
about that i think if that were to
happen to me i think i would be like
speechless
i think i'd i think i would like stick
my neck up higher and be like oh my god
i've gained the respect nah cause i know
tomorrow he's gonna [ __ ] on me
has he said because he's a [ __ ]
chinese yeah
he's a chinese dad
the same guy that asked me to help him
change his car batteries trying to give
me advice on how to change the car
battery
you know what i mean it's like does it i
don't need it i don't need to stick my
neck high up because the frying pan is
gonna come slamming down on my head
so i just have to live with it i just
know
that like
um because i've told him that before you
know like he was like asking me like why
i want to move to vegas and all that
stuff and all the reasons i gave him
he's like wow
like you're so mature you think about so
many things
and i'm like yeah like i mean i did a
lot of thinking throughout the years
and i consider a lot of stuff and like
the past 20 years of like or 15 years of
entrepreneurship it's like when we built
jk it's like building things from
scratch there's no
like entrepreneur parent you know when
bill bartle brigade built it from
scratch there's a lot of lessons
that probably within like the last 10 15
years that probably take people like 60
years to learn you know so i'm like and
because of those i adapt a lot of those
things to fatherhood and i'm thinking
about those things
and uh
so
when he
just jumps in and go why'd you put him
so time out so fast i'm like man there's
there's a book worth of explanation that
i can give you but when he just shuts
his eyes and just lays on the bed then
i'm like can't even talk to you
that's funny
just picturing him like with his uh
because he only has two uniforms i've
seen him wear
it's the white shirt undershirt yeah and
then his bandana print
oh no he has two
types of shorts yeah the blue bandanna
print and then like some green like uh
tommy bahama looking ones yeah it's
either if he's krippen or he's a
principal yeah
yeah even even even when we're like so i
think we're talking at um
at taika's jiu jitsu
and then even attacked as jiu jitsu he
was like
oh man
i realized to do good in this thing you
gotta have a killer instinct
you know and he's like i don't know i
think taika might be too fun loving and
goofy
to have a killer instinct to do good
and then i was telling him i was like
well
that's kind of like a general statement
i'm like based off of child psychology
and the different coaches we talk to
there's age uh
appropriate behavior
and i'm like from what all the coaches
have told me that killer instinct
doesn't really turn on until like six
years old because they don't even know
they don't they don't even know what a
competition really is
i'm like when they're like four or five
they're just exploring having a good
time chasing butterflies and i'm like
but you know what the most important
thing is he goes what i'm like the most
important thing is habit building so i'm
like i don't even care if tycho wins or
if he loses or if he's even learning i
don't even care what i want taika to
know is that every day
yeah if we commit to something we're
going to go we're going to go early and
whatever we do we're always going to
work hard and we're going to be good
teammates and we're going to learn and
that's the most important thing
and if we do this every single day he's
going to develop that habit and that
muscle to be a good participator and
once he's a good participator anything
he gets and he's going to be good at you
know i'm trying to teach him how to get
good at getting good yeah and then i
think that also helped my dad go wow
you're like a really good dad and you
really like think about
stuff oh my gosh that's why i
damn you are the epitome of dominate
humbly look at that oh my man
ain't trusting me i've been trying to
tell you
yeah i feel like kanye you know he's
like i live a dope life and i only do
dope [ __ ] i'm kanye west
what does he say [ __ ] when he was
watching that chappelle shorts and then
someone called him he's like yeah i'm
kanye west and i do dope [ __ ] yeah or
something like that i have a double yes
some [ __ ] like that or he's like um
i just want a room full of mirrors so i
can be with all winners
that's you dude [ __ ] party of one i
only have that relationship with my dad
because i think like
just my whole life i just felt like he's
always [ __ ] on me
so i think my whole life i always felt
like i was trying to prove something
and
you know what's cuny though and it's
never ended
but you know what's cuny what
that like that has nothing to do with
you
i know
it literally has nothing to do with it
that's the jedi level of thank you and
you take it so personally obviously you
know it's hard because like you you look
and i think [ __ ] growing up what's he
doing he's really [ __ ] us up it's just
his projections or what is it what what
because it's all him obviously obviously
it's all insecurities right like oh
insecurities 100 because he's probably
going hey i'm the father i'm the adult i
need to be guiding you you need to be
listening to me it could also be years
of just traditional mindset of like
of like the adult now has this level of
prestige you need to be the leader of
the household like it could be a lot of
those things yeah so now he feels like
he's he's fulfilling his role of like
always telling you what to do even when
he doesn't know
he's going [ __ ] i can't let him know
that i don't know
maybe that's why he also laughs
no that could be his defense mechanism
to like [ __ ] i can't let this full
school me but i'm not even gonna let it
i'm not gonna take it personally i'm
just gonna
like laugh that it's not even that
serious so when he says something like
you know you gotta have a killer
instinct to be in here
and i don't think he has a killer
instinct i don't know if that's good for
him
my normal response is like
um if you don't have anything of value
to add
please be quiet but he is adding value
what's the value he's just saying he's
already misjudging the situation but
that's his value that's the level of his
value the misjudgment
i mean it's misjudgment to you but his
level of value is he cares that's cute
so he's just saying
hey this is how much i care i'm seeing
taika in this light and i don't want
anything bad to happen to him so let's
just remove him from anything that might
potentially hurt him or change his
happy-go-lucky ways oh i see that's his
value he's just trying to shelter and
protect and like preserve taika as what
he knows him and you're just trying to
prepare taika for
life yeah you know so that's my next
level is to have
be
jedi enough to be able to understand
where
his true
meanings are coming from it's hard yeah
it's hard but yeah that is that is the
next level for sure
like really trying to
put your own [ __ ] aside and work through
your own [ __ ] by yourself because
don't expect him to help in any way yeah
i think the fact that he's changing
himself and seeing his shortcomings and
apologizing in his way
um i think that's his version
of him working with you can't help him
with any of that like it doesn't matter
how many times you have like these slide
remarks or like you try to show how
cunning you are how smart you are or
like um how much you've studied or who
you know
like um that you try to kind of like put
[ __ ] secret eggs and [ __ ] of
knowledge there
it's he has to do the work to one
recognize it to accept it you know what
i mean it's like you're you keep doing
stuff to [ __ ] shove [ __ ] down his
throat or shut his mouth but he has to
like do his own work and be like damn i
recognize it now this is what i can take
away from it
so like um i think you're just fighting
a one-sided battle yeah i think we all
are he ain't working
we all are [ __ ] fighting a one-sided
battle yeah and he's lived long enough
for i'm like you don't have to work i'll
just figure out a way to adapt
yeah
it's hard it's [ __ ] hard like i have
those relationships in my life too where
um i have to consciously
when i feel myself or when i can catch
myself feeling like my feathers are
getting ruffled
how you so brilliantly put it yeah um
when i can catch that moment then i can
i can take a step back and be like wait
whoa whoa what are they really trying to
say it's so hard to catch that moment
with my dad because the trauma's so deep
you know yeah so he's one of the few
people that could say one thing
and i'm just like boom like knee-jerk
reaction yeah whereas most times i'm
like
i feel like most of the times i feel
more like neo
you know like 20 bullets and then i'm
like
interesting thought he's he's the he's
the the boss he's the less last level
the boss you have to beat yeah
what would be your ideal relationship
um when do you think it would be you're
like
finally
this is how i wanted you to be
once he
doesn't think i'm a dumbass
but i don't think he thinks you're a
dumbass
i think he's trying to catch up to you
and that's where he comes off [ __ ] up
because he's insecure i think the way he
voices things it's already like you're
so [ __ ] dumb you don't know [ __ ] i
don't think it's that really yeah
i think he thinks you're [ __ ] super
brilliant
and i feel like he might even just have
his own um
what makes you think he thinks i'm
brilliant
from when he how he laughs at me
i don't know if he would move his whole
life out here
i don't know if he would just back off
and not question like
like how's your money situation how's
your relationship situation like he's
not in your life you know what i mean
like he's not hovering constantly
checking in in like every pocket of your
life
like he's not having serious sit-down
conversations talking to you about how
like hey
your behavior is actually really
worrying me
you know what i mean like he's at ease
like your dad doesn't doesn't seem like
someone that's like
like
he can't relax because he has to like
work because his son's a [ __ ] loser
or an idiot i see do you know what i
mean yeah i see maybe i'm missing the
big picture
yeah because someone like
like someone who's who who's really um
who really cares for their kids
i don't know
and they see that their kids are headed
down the wrong path i don't know if they
would be um
as comfortable as your dad appears to be
i see so it's it's his comfort with the
big picture that allows him to be
nitpicky with the small things which is
why sometimes he says things that i
perceive as
as he thinks i'm a dumbass but it's just
him not catching up to me
yeah i think um
so one he's been single for a long time
yeah so he's never really had i don't
even know what his friendship circles
like but he's never really had people to
check him right like your true circle
those people are going to help you um
evolve and they're going to tell you
hopefully they tell you the truth and
they're good people that are going to
check your behavior yeah right like i'm
grateful to have you who checks my
behavior i'm grateful i have people like
joe david you know my girl group like
they'll check me on some [ __ ] if if it's
out of line yeah right there like i know
their intention's always going to be to
help develop me
so like if i do some [ __ ] you're going
to be like yo this isn't like you right
i don't know if he's had that maybe he's
only
i don't know i don't know what his thing
is so he's probably lived life this way
and it's got him this far where he has a
comfortable savings he owns his house he
doesn't really have
debt like he's very comfortable he could
probably he probably has enough to even
help his brothers and sisters you know
what i mean like he's
he's he's well off
he has enough
um so like
now considering you know the culture and
like how he was raised and probably what
values and traditions were instilled in
him
he needs to guide you and now he
probably sees himself as a failure where
he's like [ __ ] i couldn't make i
couldn't stay with my son's wife for my
son's sake
you know that's probably one [ __ ]
broken thing in his mirror where he's
like [ __ ] okay well let me see what else
i can do yeah let me at least like pay
for my son's college so that he can just
not worry about that cool i got that
covered and like i think he's trying to
give you any sort of value that he has
in his own way where it is covered with
insecurity and he knows that you're
smart but i think he's trying to still
be a provider at any capacity
and he does come from like
a [ __ ] farm town or some [ __ ] you
said right
so like there's just so many differences
i think all he's really trying to do is
just provide his version of value to you
even though for you might come off to
crass or like it might like you might be
sensitive to him
yeah you know you might he might be
looking at your at our generation and
going you guys are all [ __ ] like i
tell you this way and you let these
words affect you yeah it's like that's
your fault you know like it could be all
that yeah
i could see that i could definitely see
my dad always trying to help
like in any way that he can yeah he's
very nimble yeah i was i was listening
you know how like you can follow like
those inspiration
ig pages
and like they'll have like um
like different philosophers or just
different actors that are like renowned
and [ __ ] um
and then and they give you like their
golden nuggets and they'll give you like
those little excerpts of like a speech
they were giving my favorite are always
the ones from mike tyson
i don't know if i've seen one yo but in
his raw way deep
[ __ ] and in his raw way like it's it it
definitely sticks with me did you hear
did you see the one where he was well
you don't see it but there was one he
was talking to another guy
uh i think he's a rapper or something
and he was talking about how like
if someone pisses you off you can't
state pith
and he's like wait what because they own
you yeah because they own you you're
their slave
and he goes no i'm pissed he goes yeah
but you're in control of your emotions
and then you're like oh what the [ __ ]
this is coming from the guy that's like
i want to eat your children you know i'm
a [ __ ] you til you love me yeah i'm a
[ __ ] tale love me i'm a conqueror no
one could defeat me i'ma eat your
children yeah now he's like you can't
get mad at all
that's dope though he went to the depths
of his extremes man and he's like this
isn't this isn't the way to live it's
heavy yeah um no so they they had one of
selma hayek right
and who's selma hayek whatever but she
was talking about how like you have
basically along those lines right about
like you have control over how you feel
no one else should have control over
that so she was saying you're the one
that adds emotions
to
what people say oh yeah true because
she's like imagine he was saying the
same [ __ ] to you in french
he could be [ __ ] yelling at you but
if he's saying it in french you're not
really gonna get emotionally rolled up
you might just be like whoa what's this
dude's problem like everything is gonna
be on like what's their problem you're
gonna try to understand what they're
trying to say but they could be saying
like you [ __ ] stupid idiot you
[ __ ] suck i hate you i wish you were
never born just looking at your face
pisses me off they could be telling you
all of that in french
is it going to affect you
yeah
no because you don't know what the hell
is going on and you can't because if
words really hurt then you should be
feeling that yeah and you should be
getting sad or pissed or whatever but
it's whatever we're adding to it yeah
that [ __ ] us up so like that's what i'm
saying so when he says stuff to you
it's literally you taking it that way
unfortunately because if he calls you
like if
i don't know if a person on the street
were to come at you and call you a
[ __ ] dumb ass it's probably not going
to bother you that's not at all yeah
cause you you're like who the [ __ ] are
you yeah i don't give a [ __ ] about what
you think about me yeah i'm not gonna be
the slave
you know so that like
that goes to show you it's literally 100
your problem in your problem alone yeah
bummer huh yeah because isn't it easier
to blame the other person to be like why
don't they [ __ ] change
it is easy it's not easier
why because it's easier to change
yourself no i know it feels good to
blame other people that's what i mean
but it's actually easier to change
yourself okay yes you're right my uh
correction it feels better yes it does
yeah
yeah but it's [ __ ] like you said it's
it's the jedi mind tricks you know where
you have to like
[ __ ] get to that place yeah it's like
being in the car on the freeway where
everyone's driving crazy it feels good
to flip everyone off
but it's actually harder to get everyone
to drive straight like hey drive
straight it's easier to just go
and then you're out of the mess yeah so
it's easier to control your own car yeah
yeah
it is and like as i talk like it's so i
have such a clear vision you know like
as i'm talking about you and your dad's
relationship and what i think he's doing
i could be absolutely wrong but i don't
feel like i'm wrong um
but then when it comes to my own stuff
i know these things and then i'll get
like emotionally caught up in things and
i'm like [ __ ] yeah you fell victim to it
because you have your own trauma yeah
you know like the stuff like the
relationship between you and your family
whatever it's like 30 years deep so when
they say something goes boom it ignites
i know something with me and my dad you
know it's just sometimes he'll say
something that other people are like
what are you talking about i'm like oh
you don't know this [ __ ]
it was like the ratatouille you know
he goes he takes a bite of it and he
goes and tony as a kid and his mom made
him yeah yeah yeah yeah this is like
the negative side and it's like me
back in like the kitchen and my dad's
whooping my ass or something like that
you know yeah yeah
dang
so living with your dad's been good huh
ultimately i love it uh because one
you know one thing that my dad told me
that i was like oh man i almost [ __ ]
cried on the spot you didn't tell me i
did tell you oh okay fine is damn chill
out whoa whoa whoa hey chill pickle
is uh you know what he was telling me he
was like you know what i've been
thinking about i may been thinking back
and out of all the quans that i can
think of
not just in your generation so like
asians it's very generational thinking
right like my dad
and his brothers are the same generation
they all have kids
and then uh which is like my dad i'm my
dad's son and his brother
would have a kid and that's my cousin
right so all cousins are in this
generation my dad is in this generation
my grandpa has a bunch and it's like a
giant pyramid right so at the top if
there's one
great grandpa
um there's hundreds of
cousins down here he goes thinking all
the way back and just all the stories
i've heard of even my grandpa he says
which is my great grandpa he goes i
think you're the most successful quan
in the whole kwan pyramid
and my dad has six brothers and sisters
i think his dad had like seven or eight
brothers and sisters so it's a giant
pyramid
and then when he said that i was like
and knowing that my dad came from like a
war-torn country in china uh back when
communism took over and to just even be
able to see like my dad
walking around
a 5 000 square foot home
with like 40-foot ceilings it's just
it's just a trip every day you know
knowing my dad ate his cat he only had
one school uniform that he would
literally have to wear
come home yeah wash it and then hope it
doesn't rain that night so that it can
dry for the next day
my dad said he barely had money for
cigarettes when he was eight because he
was they've all been smoking and they
would share one cigarette yeah i was
like whoa whoa whoa that statement
sounded wrong i know i'm not a math whiz
here but that just doesn't add up dude
well he could he couldn't even afford
two cigarettes
he was smoking since he was eight that's
the type of country that's like a third
world country you know oh you're
obviously a [ __ ] flower to him then
the fact that he calls you stupid and
that affects your heart you can never
talk [ __ ] about this new generation
[ __ ] flower boy fine but let's see
where all that stuff
where it came from he was smoking since
he was eight little [ __ ]
and then to see my dad like like knock
on her like crate and barrel couches you
know it's just it just it just
oh we're [ __ ] in his eyes first sure
dude it feels very cuny that uh
he sees you in that light or you were
here
he sees me that as a successful
quan
and also i'm able to provide for him in
that way to even
open his eyes to that you know because
if you would if you were to think back
when he grew up in communist china
like
aside from like let's say his brothers
and sisters don't know where we live
right if they visited vegas they'd be
walking around our neighborhood going
wow you see those houses out in there
one day those houses are crazy you know
but then my dad could go to the front
gate and go come on in my son owns one
of those houses and so when he told me
that i was like oh
i'm afraid
what did you what was your reply to that
i just was just taken back by it and i
was like oh wow i was like
i was like are you sure
he goes yeah i'm sure
i'm like wow what about his brother i
thought his brother was pretty ballin
yeah but i guess uh ballin for their era
you know i see
i think also like not just
ballin but what they've built i see it
his brother is pretty well off but he
worked for a company you know i think
like everything that we have we created
yeah yeah literally like jk like air but
we created a production company yeah
none of us interned at like paramount
pictures yeah we don't know jack [ __ ]
borrow brigade2 it was like none of us
were
gym
gym owners before or personal trainers
we we had a like that style of gym
didn't even exist we literally just
created things that we thought would be
cool you know so i think my dad sees
that and sees the life that we have
we're even like
uh seeing that we designed our life to
finish at
three our work at three so we could take
taika jiu jitsu every day because it
means a lot to all of us you know and
like yeah and take my dad to ayuki shabu
shabu where he was blown that totally 20
bucks
you know just like yeah you get two
appetizers you get all you can eat meat
any broth flavor you want and then they
end the meal with ice cream that's a
[ __ ] bargain dude that's vegas baby
he's like this basically go out of
business
you know it's like just seeing like all
of that and how how often we take taika
to the park and the the free time that
we have because you know my dad comes
from a generation where like
my mom was working overtime no do your
dad consume a generation or he's smoking
at eight yeah you get it dude yeah the
parent you like who i don't even i
haven't seen my dad for a whole week
yeah the [ __ ] eight-year-old or the
[ __ ] ten-year-old was taking care of
the eight that's the dad yeah and the
two-year-old and the one-year-old yeah i
get it yeah
[ __ ]
yeah stop being a little [ __ ] bart fine
that's true i am a [ __ ] god
okay well that's not true
it feels good calling people out i've
been
unscathed
this whole [ __ ] you haven't talked
any [ __ ] to me i never talked to you
yeah that's true um
so it looks like we've reached the end
of this podcast
anything you want to add i do actually
what the [ __ ] this is the second one in
a row because i've been working on stuff
all right what are you working on so
this week
is the official launch of my mentorship
program
big cuny
congratulations you're so supportive of
me no i'm not i hope i hope you fail so
if you're interested
in
mentorship so like
anything with personal development
entrepreneurship or even planning or
designing your life
i've made a lot of mistakes over the
last
10 15 years and i think people can see
that because i've been vlogging
my whole life since like the inception
of jk and all that stuff and which is
probably why i get questions about these
things all the time entrepreneurship
personal development designing your life
life balance and all those things and
they're like they want to see how i did
it so i have a lot of insight and a lot
of funny stories to share so i'm
starting a mentorship program called
times 100. i love it and the website is
times-1
and if you go to that website and if
you're interested in participating in
this eight-week mentorship program you
just enter your email and then we'll
take care of the rest on the back end
and uh what you can expect is eight
weekly lessons and principles that i
personally teach that i live my life by
and then afterwards we have a quick q a
anything that people want to bring up so
it's like a very interactive thing
and it's a one hour session
every single week for eight weeks and
then we'll close it off so as soon as we
hit
enrollment
uh enrollment capacity it closes it
closes and then since this is my very
first class there's going to be a
special introductory price
and then after that it's going to go to
a regular price so don't miss out go
check it out go to
times-100.com i'm so so happy that
you're doing this i'm so happy that
you're sharing
the parts of you that i have so
selfishly enjoyed um and and have um
benefited from
um i'm stoked that one you're doing it
because you're such a funny guy two
you're doing it or the second reason
you're doing it is because you've had
such a colorful life like you come from
a very unique background
um
and uh
like with divorced parents and just very
eccentric very unique
polar opposite parents
um so you have a lot of life experience
in that regard you're the king of um uh
what are those like analogies analogies
i [ __ ] love your analogies because
you can take any complex [ __ ]
life puzzle and you can you can put it
into this digestible analogy and i love
love love love love if you guys didn't
pick up on this the part where he was
please rewind it but the part where he's
talking to his dad at jiu jitsu about
why he thinks it's important for taiga
to stick in jiu jitsu is that you pick
up on life patterns
and instead of
so i don't know how to do that to to to
reduce something to its very basic
element so that i can understand why it
is that i'm doing what i'm doing you're
really good at that so the fact that
you're doing this eight week course and
like i know that it's going to get
boiled down to such a basic element that
now you can start building patterns upon
that i'm just so excited um and and for
everyone listening please do yourself a
favor and i'm not just saying this
because i love him because i i don't
like telling him these things
but you would be doing yourself a
disservice if you didn't sign up today
like honestly so what's that website one
more time because i just probably erased
it from everyone's memory times
100.com
okay there you go um so thank you so
much for listening and we'll see you
next week can i tell you a funny story
what
the only reason why it's times-100.com
yeah was because times100.com was gonna
cost me like five thousand dollars
to get the website i put a dash in there
and it's way cheaper oh yeah there we go
we keep it real yeah okay bye